they do their homework on time their
writing is neat they keep their bedroom
tidy they're often a little shy they
want to help their parents they use
their breaks when cycling down a hill
because they don't pose many immediate
problems we tend to assume that all is
well with good children they aren't the
target for particular concern that all
goes to the kids who are graffitiing the
underpass people imagine that good
children are fine because they do
everything that's expected of them and
that of course is precisely the problem
the secret sorrows and future
difficulties of the good boy or girl
begin with their inner need for
excessive compliance the good child
isn't good because by a quirk of nature
they simply have no inclination to be
anything else they are good because they
have no other option their goodness
is a necessity rather than a choice many
good children are good out of love of a
depressed harris parent who makes it
clear they just couldn't cope with any
more complications or difficulties or
maybe they're very good to soothe a
violently angry parent who could become
catastrophic ly frightening at any sign
of less-than-perfect conduct but this
sort of repression of more challenging
emotions though it produces short-term
pleasant obedience stores up a huge
amount of difficulty in later life
practiced educators and parents should
spot signs of exaggerated politeness and
treat it as the grave danger it really
is the good child becomes a keeper of
too many secrets and an appalling
communicator of unpopular but important
things they say lovely words they're
experts in satisfying the expectations
of their audiences but their real
thoughts and feelings stay buried and
then generate psychosomatic symptoms
twitches sudden outbursts and sulfurous
bitterness the sickness of the good
child is that they have no experience of
other people being able to tolerate
their badness they have missed out a
vital crippling
chorded to the healthy child that of
being able to display envious greedy
egomaniacal sides and yet be tolerated
and loved nevertheless the good person
typically has particular problems around
sex as a child they may have been
praised for being pure and innocent as
they become an adult however like all of
us they discover the ecstasy's of sex
which can be beautifully perverse and
excitingly disgusting but this may be
radically at odds with a picture of what
they believe they're allowed to be like
they may in response disavow their
desires go cold and detach from their
bodies or perhaps give in to their
longings only in a disproportionate way
that's destructive to other bits of
their lives and leaves them disgusted
and frightened at work the good adult
has problems too as a child they follow
the rules never make trouble and take
care not to annoy anyone but following
the rules won't get you very far in
adult life almost everything that's
interesting worth doing or important
will meet with a degree of opposition a
brilliant idea will always disappoint
certain people and yet maybe very much
worth holding on to
the good child is condemned to career
mediocrity and sterile people pleasing
being properly mature involves a frank
on frightened relationship with one's
own dark sides complexities and
ambitions it involves accepting that not
everything that makes us happy will
please others or be honored as
especially nice by society but that it
can be important to explore and hold on
to it nevertheless the desire to be good
is one of the loveliest things in the
world but in order to have a genuinely
good life we may sometimes need to be by
the standards of the good child
fruitfully and bravely bad we love
bringing you these films if you want to
help us to keep bringing you thoughtful
content please consider supporting us by
visiting our shop at the link on your
screen now
you